so that was the thing black mirrors
season 4 episode 3 krokodil this is your
spoiler warning cuz I'm gonna be talking
about this thing and how the inciting
incident is not shocking actually just
the way it was being shot I'm like
when's the body gonna crack into the
Winship boom boom there it is
and so I'm watching it and so that
happening
didn't you know it wasn't shocking
especially kind of saw it coming but
then how much time it's lingering on
disposing of the body because what
usually happens in these situations is
once characters make the decision to
hide the body you kind of jump to you
know just make you clear what they did
with it you know take the time to have
the guy who run to his car and get a
sleeping bag and and and weigh it down
with rocks and all of it so like right
there that's the first level of
unsettling cinclant
sinking in as we just linger on this
process of getting rid of the body a lot
more and then we get to the hotel and
the whole thing there again it's not
exceptionally unexpected and more to the
point it's at that point it's not yet
unsympathetic it was his mistake both
the initial hit and the decision to get
rid of that body that she doesn't want
to have to pay for I'm still thinking in
my head as I'm watching this I'm like
you know you're making the decision that
the risk to what you have now is ranks
above what someone else has already lost
because the reason you wants to talk
about it is the the wife of the guy they
killed just never knew and yeah but
she's not again she's not unsympathetic
and it's not an unsympathetic situation
we're like look for what infer how she
got into the situation what she stands
to lose like I'd like to think I
wouldn't go there but I get it but then
again we have the long lingering
disposal of the body like her driving
around this thing in the backseat how
much time we spend focusing on her
getting it out of the hotel room in the
first place her sitting in the car
talking with her family with this body
in the back that's the sort of thing
that I don't remember ever seeing played
straight like I can I can actually think
of times that I've seen you know this
much emphasis put on the disposal of the
body but usually it's been times where
it's been played for comedy I mean dark
comedy granted but it's like oh you know
just got off the phone camera pans over
you practically hear the laugh try God
there's the body right there it's almost
like it was listening you know thinking
of things like the bit with with Jackie
boy and in Sin City or you know any one
of a million you know usually very bad
dark comedies you know where they think
making jokes about dead people as
somehow edgy but that I can't remember
seeing this much lingering emphasis put
on the disposal of the body where it was
allowed to sink in how unnerving that
actually is so we get that and then
we've been seeing the insurance
investigator and I actually I really
like it's not as pivotal to sort of the
thrust of the episode as some of the
other technology things in
and the previous two episodes episodes
I've seen keep in mind this is only the
third episode I've seen it all because
I'm starting with season four so it
wasn't it was more a logistical plot
point the plot didn't actually really
hinge on it cuz it was just about this
woman and the depths that she was
prepared to sink to but I do want to
talk about the technology thing with the
whole memory thing I liked it I liked
that they acknowledge what so few movies
especially sci-fi movies they claim to
read your memory ever acknowledged which
is that memory is fallible it can change
how well you remember one specific
aspect it will depend on how much that
triggered a reaction from you a bunch of
stuffs gonna be blurry episode but it's
a suggestion like with the the dentists
you know he in in his memories this
woman is wearing a lime coat and he gets
told it was yellow and then just the
memory changes I love that that gets to
acknowledge because human memory is like
that but it's so often when you're
dealing with the memory recording as any
kind of a plot device in a movie or
though or a story or whatever they treat
memory like it's this absolute record in
this infallible document and it's not
that's not how human memory works so I
really like that that was acknowledged
as part of this and that did actually
pay into the things as as this woman
tries to try so hard to focus and not
think about the things she doesn't want
this machine to pick up and then the
head but it does and that's where things
really really started to go because at
that point with the with the insurance
investigator the this this woman is no
longer just reacting viscerally to an
immediate threat to her life she is
making decisions I'm not saying there's
no duress there's a little duress but
she is taking the time and weighing her
options and making these choices too
Hill people and what's really disturbing
is that it is sold in a way that's like
yeah I buy that it which is really hard
it's really hard to push characters into
these kinds of actions and not have it
just seem silly but this doesn't and
then like and and every step it becomes
less and less understandable less and
less relatable as she escalates from
helping to cover up someone else's
mistake doing something possibly just in
the heat of the moment because of she
wasn't responsible to the initial
situation and it threatens everything
about her life to making a much more
measured decision of the degree she's
willing to go to to try and preserve her
life to actually breaking into someone
else's house to kill a man and then to
kill a baby I mentioned in the last
episode how endangered children don't
sit well for me and that's they and and
I'm not knocking it as a storytelling
device it can be justified in this case
for the story that this was telling you
I would say that it is but hmm it is it
is about the most down to the core
visceral negative reaction that
something can get from me but not like
in a screaming angry way just in a no no
no no no no yes I will say and from what
I'm hearing from some of my colleagues
and comments I shouldn't expect this but
I will take the silver lining of that
guinea pig getting picked up and it
looked like they were gonna hook it up
to the memory device I don't care if
that's questionable I I need to believe
that she
suffers that she is caught and she pays
because just know so this was really
good I've seen so far this was the one
that I found the most disturbing I think
you SS Callister was the most
existentially scary the Archangel was
the one that was sort of the and I don't
mean this as a knock but sort of the
easiest to wrap my head around this one
was just sinking lis depressing as it
showed you the worst depths that a human
could sink to but doing it over a course
of progressive steps that makes it all
the more believable that somebody would
actually do that and how believable it
was in terms of explaining her
motivations and how she got to where she
is is what made it unnerving so that
hits black mirror crocodile so have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are truffling
down the comments let's talk about it do
all the things like subscribe I'm on
Twitter I got an email I got all these
things links for all the stuffs down
below the podcast etc so that's it for
this one and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]